hello and welcome to grenades Marvel
spider-man on ps4 is a pretty great game
as it's a Spidey superhero outing it's
jam-packed full of references to the
Marvel Universe but there's also shed
loads of nods to video games movies
music and some random occurrences that I
think you should see for yourself here
are 60 Easter eggs and cultural
references we found in marvel spider-man
let's start with a pretty serious one
first the reflections on high buildings
almost always show the Empire State
Building I mean it doesn't even need to
be near there are a few exceptions to
this rule though crawl up this building
in Greenwich to see what many people are
calling the Twin Towers check behind you
those buildings aren't there this
potentially is a subtle nod of respect
to the former World Trade Center which
suffered tragedy in the 9/11 terror
attacks on September the 11th 2001 the
Twin Towers may be gone from the New
York skyline but they'll never be
forgotten as we're all gamers here let's
look at the video game references in
Marvel spider-man first a book star over
in the Midtown district this is Tom
Raider it's a reference to Lara Croft
and the Tomb Raider series the latest
game in the Tomb Raider series shadow of
the Tomb Raider released in the same
week as spider-man on ps4 coincidence or
a nod to a competitor you decide I
reckon someone who works on spider-man
also worked on the Tomb Raider series
around this area of the world you can
find a game store named gamer paradise
looking inside you'll spot spider-man
plush toys and the display console
looking like an oversized Nintendo Wii
putting that image through recognition
software and I'm told the closest
console to that design is in fact the
PSX created back in 2003 this beast was
a ps2 hybrid with a digital video
recorder think of it like how Microsoft
attempted to sell the Xbox one
originally a media center needless to
say it was a commercial failure
oh and that controller in front
recognition software tells us it's based
on the Superboy a handheld console that
can play SNES cartridges Super Nintendo
capabilities in the palm of your hand as
we're already talking about fake
consoles look around the world and pick
up a PS Vita rip
gonna have something to do on stakeouts
track down the Radio City Music Hall it
looks damn impressive but take a moment
to read the ad lines coming soon are the
quarks with djr see the quarks
must be a nod to captain Qwark from
Ratchet and Clank which is likely where
the RC part comes from Ratchet and Clank
to those that don't know insomniac
created spider-man on ps4 and Ratchet
and Clank as far back as 2002 on the ps2
there's another Ratchet and Clank
reference if you complete four different
stunts in a single web swing you earn
the rank of Spidey Merc marks those that
played Ratchet and Clank will remember
the Tony Hawk inspired mechanic with a
trick called the twisty Mach marks hands
down my favorite Easter Egg in the whole
game is during a side mission in which
you stop would be bank robbers once you
are tasked with fallen this guy to his
apartment take a moment to listen to
their voices their clothing and their
names
he's already picking up a seat
all right Romans ready and we are
running late let's roll
they're on the move it's Nico and Roman
from GTA 4 what an absolutely brilliant
way to reference one of the greatest
open-world games in history why do I
suddenly want to go bowling let's go
remember spider-man 2 on the ps2 or the
PSP well there are two references to
that former great don't ever go back and
play them by the way they are far better
in your memory than they are to actually
play remember the most repetitive
mission ever yeah the one where that
annoying brat would keep losing his
balloon it turns out that that little
actually drew spider-man a picture for
collecting his balloon around a hundred
times looks like our work finally paid
off if you remember the balloon boy you
must remember the pizza delivery
missions the soundtrack for those
missions can be heard if you stand close
enough to one of the pizza restaurants
found around the island the one which
works the most is the one in the
financial district it's quite difficult
to hear but have a go
[Music]
if you can't make it out I'm sure you're
having nightmares from the ps2
Pizza Delivery missions Oh No dr.
Connors class Oh No
dr. Connors class let's move over to
movie references now remember this
cutscene after defeating the king win
[Music]
so kiss now this is a nod to the kiss in
the movie version of spider-man from
back in 2002 where Spidey and MJ shared
this upside-down saliva swap were in the
same movie trilogy this time in 2004
spider-man saved a group of New Yorkers
from Doc Ock using webs to slow a train
here's how that scene is referenced into
this game no brakes no problem
they totally worked last time urine is
one more reference to Tobey Maguire's
version of spider-man this time from the
third movie in 2007 can you remember the
cringy scene where Peter is dancing down
the street it's the watch doesn't it
well those ridiculous hand gestures can
be performed in the spider-man video
game go on give it a go straight down
the street
tapping square hashtag finger guns as
the game is set in New York some of the
original architecture is there in the
game one of which will be instantly
recognizable by Ghostbuster fans over in
the financial district you can find the
fire house which was converted into the
Ghostbusters headquarters round the back
of the building is a piece of graffiti
in the shape of a ghost I'm not sure if
that's there in real life but either way
it's a reference to the Ghostbusters
movie other film references include this
movie entitled Kate and Kevin which
takes usual romantic movie tropes in
poster form there's one film in
particular which it reminds me of the
ugly truth starring Gerard Butler and
that woman who can't act yes I wash the
film to have that opinion there's a
stereotypical action movie photo
scattered around the world one of which
is a secret photo this image is an
amalgam of all the Lethal Weapon movie
posters including similar heroes the
poses and the title which refers to a
new cop on day one and a cop reaching
retirement on his last day because
oh and those trees in the background
they are taken from the Beverly Hills
Cop two poster the 80s were pretty cool
there's more references to the games
developers insomniac which can be found
around the world including their studio
which you can spot over in the Midtown
district if you're wondering if all the
developers weigh 600 pounds and have
never seen sunlight check them out for
yourself
all their images can be found on the
volunteers wall in the feast kitchen
they look like real people who'd a thunk
it oh and jump into camera mode and
check out the insomniac logo on the
police radars speaking of photo mode
attempt to use it during a fight with a
rocket launcher wielding fault zoom in
on the rocket to read the small print
because the blast is guaranteed to kill
spiders the attention to detail is
ridiculous in this game Spidey shouts
out quips as and fights around the city
he notes that his ripped costume may
reveal his three chest hairs not good
can't have people taking pictures of my
three chest hairs well complete the game
to 100% and unlock the underwear version
of spider-man without your camera and
look at his chest one two yeah yeah he's
right he only has three chests as I
can't believe I'm Satya accounting Peter
Parker's chest has this is so surreal
can't have people taking pictures of my
three chest hairs when in battle and
additional troops join the fray Spidey
say this is a nod to kelis and her
milkshake song
in other words Oh before I forget did
you ever see Greg Miller and his push
for his version of spider-man to be
included in the game
shirtless spider-man me a beacon of hope
for middle-aged slightly overweight
videogame geeks during the party scene
in the game shirtless spider-man can be
spotted let's move over to a buttload of
Marvel references I'll try to keep away
from the obvious like look there's the
Avengers tower but I'm sure I'll still
say something completely obvious so
apologies in advance there's another
spider-man quip in the opening shot of
the game amongst all these post-it notes
is this beaut need a catchphrase
it's webbing time any superhero loving
individual will know this is a nod to
the Power Rangers and their line it's
worth the time whilst on this screen
let's look at two other notes with
initials upon them ts looks to be Tony
Stark and his offer to be an Avenger
maybe and this one is not certain but RR
could be Reed Richards the leader of the
Fantastic Four
looks like he needs a new suit Tony
Stark's damage control company has its
own spot in the cityscape in the
spider-man homecoming movie this
organization played a huge part in the
story as Tony Stark set it up to clean
up the problems the Avengers battles
left behind in the comic books Tony
Stark and the kingpin co-owned this
venture
similarly the Roxxon corporation can be
found here too in the comic books Roxxon
was responsible for the deaths of Tony
Stark's mother and father so this oil
giant isn't to be underestimated
speaking of crippling death and
depression head to the far north of the
map to find Uncle Ben's grave pay your
respects for a hidden trophy and snap a
photo for a secret suit challenge more
on that soon now's a good time to throw
in the Stan Lee cameo in spider-man on
ps4 I knew it was here you knew it was
here everybody knew it was here but we
can't have a Marvel Easter Egg video
without this great man loves seeing you
two together again you always were my
favorites
during the mission at Fisk's auction
house keep an eye out for his signature
Kane and his cello which he named after
his wife Vanessa you can see boast as
spider-man but you'll likely destroy
them viewing them as MJ is a little
easier
nice hated this Kane so tacky another
easter egg which can only be found by MJ
is over at Oscorp in the hidden room
left on the desk and grenades which look
to be prototypes for goblin grenades
another villain we can likely expect it
in the second game the Spidey squad
dedicated to bringing independent
spider-man news to the masses is
referenced in two ways in the games
yours first the strap MJ has around her
camera Dom's their design and later in
the game it's a collectible to here's
what Peter thinks of the Spidey squad
the Spidey squad my one and only fan
club when Jameson's going off on me it
helps to remember they're out there
during the party scene where we
encountered the shirtless spider-man
you'll also be able to see the original
designs for other spider-man villains
most noticeably electro electro caught
my eye right away and his ridiculous
costume that reminds me what do you
think of is redesigning the game the
electric bolt mask is still there if you
look hard enough but it's now an
electrical scar rather than the original
hood I digress back to the party you'll
find vulture the original design for
Rhino and even fishbowl head himself
makes an appearance
good old Mysterio hey what's wrong with
you I worked on that helmet for a week
another villain makes an appearance in a
sidequest who you may not know just yet
this is screwball she debuted in 2008
and is completely fixated on celebrity
and views on video sounds like every
youtuber I know by the way
like comment and subscribe
screwball during the mission to find the
imposter version of spider-man he
briefly mentions the chameleon turn
around someone's impersonating me it
could be the chameleon again I've got to
pick up his trail if you don't know him
he's the master of disguise and has the
honor of being the first supervillain
spider-man ever faced back in 1963 other
characters briefly mentioned include
flash who once bullied Peter at school
but went on to idolize spider-man just
take a look at the notice board over at
the soup kitchen veteran homelessness is
down but still way too high good thing
my buddy Flash Thompson is doing is best
to fix that Eddie Brock Peters former
coworker at the Daily Bugle and the
original venom character is also in the
world but only in writing take a look at
the collectible good luck card you find
in the world look close enough and
you'll see Eddie's message written when
Peter left the bugle I know the venom
reference can be found during our first
meeting with Yuri so why'd you call
neither date to the policeman's ball
you've got a black & white suit yeah
it's quite subtle but if you weren't
aware the most requested suit asked for
by the funds was the black and white
venom suit this is as close as we'll get
at this time but I'm certain the second
game will have venom in and hopefully
carnage too let's look at references to
other Marvel franchises which make an
appearance in spider-man's first outing
on ps4 I found four references to
daredevil some a little more obvious
than others Nelson and Murdock business
card can be found as a collectible in
the game oh yeah a blind guy gave me his
card in case spider-man ever needs a
lawyer wait hold on if he's blind how
did he know I have a spider-man their
office is also available to be
photographed for Wells Jim pops up
that's where Daredevils dad used to
train as a boxer if you don't know what
happened to him
well let's just move on the last
daredevil Easter Egg comes in the shape
of Josie's bar in Hell's Kitchen a
drinking hole which is regularly filled
with criminals so it's the perfect place
to learn about your enemies ever heard
of R and R the run corporation I don't
know much about that organization but it
plays an important role in Iron Fist
daredevil and even Jessica Jones so the
tower can be found in the open world Oh
segue Jessica Jones is a private
investigator agency is here in hell
kitchen - it's quite subtle but it's
here by the way does anybody watch the
TV show for daredevil iron fist or
Jessica Jones I'm very tempted to start
watching one but would like a push in
the right direction which should I start
with a short wine one of the landmarks
in New York is the charging bull a huge
bronze sculpture in the financial
district it's here in the videogame but
it's a little different the ball has
been replaced with a dog
this giant Bulldog is actually from
Marvel's be in humans and is the
official protector of their royal family
you can call him lockjaw other marvel
nods include the sanctum sanctorum
Doctor Strange protects in the movies
and the comics it even has the circular
window drawn back in 1963 cool window
but I always get the feeling something
strange is going on in their place
silver sable made a brief appearance in
the spider-man game and reading her
backstory we learned she is from sim
carrier it's a fictional country I spent
three hours searching the globe for it
sim carrier gets two references in the
game first in kingpins auction as the
creator of his famous cigars sim courier
weren't they just in the news but later
in the open world you'll be able to
track down this in Korean embassy not to
be left out Black Panthers home country
of Wakanda
has its own embassy here too and when I
think the charla got his powers from
being bitten by a radioactive panther
let's quickly go through three quick
references to the DC Universe found on
the streets of Spidey's New York look
hard enough and you'll find this star
which is impossible to read slant it
sideways and it says trusters league
which may be a coincidence but I believe
it's a nod to the Justice League during
fight scenes at night it's possible for
our enemy to be spotted in a search
light leaving Peter to say this
there's also a running gag about the
Spidey mobile throughout the entire game
which was originally created in contrast
to the Batmobile
hope you're getting tired sometimes I
wish I had a spider mobile there's a
hidden photo challenge in spider-man on
ps4 if you need a guide I'll link it now
completing this task of finding 50
hidden photos will unlock the Empire
State University suit this suit is
reference to Peter's University which
was also attended by Captain Universe
Squirrel Girl the human dog hybrids Nova
black cat and of course the webslinger
himself and that's only a few names on
the list
and finally Easter Egg number 60 the
saddest easter egg in history looking at
this theater advertisement you'll find
this message Maddie will you marry me
this is from Tyler Schulz who asked
insomniac to let him propose in the game
to his surprise they bloody well did
fast-forward to the game's release and
Tyler got back in touch with the
Internet and sadly his girlfriend Maddie
left him three weeks before the game
released it gets worse she left him for
his own brother what an absolute on the
bright side of all this insomniac and
Tyler are currently talking about
changing the easter egg to represent
something positive in his life such as a
mural for his grandmother
oh what a crappy way to finish his video
I'm absolutely devastated for Tyler but
I think he's actually dodged a bullet
with her so there you have it 60 Easter
eggs I found in Marvel spider-man on the
ps4 I know there's a ton more but I
needed to stop somewhere and 60 sounded
like a perfect number let me know what
you found in the comments below and if
there's enough I'll make a follow-up
video who I'm absolutely shattered but
it's been worth it it's been a pleasure
I'm Adam from PlayStation granade I'll
see you next time
[Music]